ok ich begrüße ganz herzlich zur
heutigen sitzung heute haben wir uns ein
neues thema vorgenommen nämlich heute
geht es um virtualität es ist ein ganz
zentraler begriff und bevor wir auf
diesen begriff heute mehr eingehen
werden auf dem griff der virtualität
möchte ich noch mal etwas sagen
zum thema der hausarbeit ich wurde schon
gebeten dazu ein bisschen was zu sagen
und möchte jetzt macht kommen und zwar
sie haben bestimmt gemerkt wir haben das
schon einige sitzungen hier habt zu
verschiedenen themen und zu langsam aber
sicher muss man sich auch mal gedanken
machen worüber man dann die hausarbeit
schreiben möchte jetzt biete ich ihnen
jemals unter anderem sie können sich
überlegen ob sie sich beschreiben es ist
doch nicht die definitiven liste das
heißt nicht dass nur für diese themen
schreiben können sie können auch selbst
gerne sich aussuchen
aber ich denke dass da so ein paar
interessante darunter sein können zb im
elephant ist künstliche intelligenz
intelligent dann müsste man erst mal
klären
überhaupt künstlichen es vor in welchen
bereichen und da müsste man sich fragen
welche systemische prädikat also
intelligent verständigt begrifflich
bedeutung unseres ganzen liefern
angemessen auf dieses system überhaupt
zu treffen oder ob das nicht so einen
hohen eigentliche training ist wo man
eigentlich davon gar nicht so sprechen
es ist also eine möglichkeit
ich hatte ja das jetzt immer gesagt
begriffe könnte man eventuell sogar
solchen systemen zu sprechen
erkennt das system wenn man nur begriff
eben auf eine bestimmte weise definieren
begriffe eben definiert als abgrenzung
von anderen muster wenn man ein muster
so internalisiert hat das ist in jedem
fall ist erkennt und abgrenzt von
anderen mustern ich hatte da das den
begriff der abschaffung gebracht wissen
sie noch was der begriff der abschaltung
solle etwas abschaltung bedeutet
abschattung schreiben
warum wissen hilft der phänomenologie
bedeutet so viel wie dass man einen
gegenstand von ganz verschiedenen zeiten
phänomenologischen als einen segen
gegenstände erkennen kann zb kann dieses
größer umgehen und es zeigt sich hier
auf ganz verschiedene weise das heißt es
muss davon diese kult muss so verfasst
sein das ist es was ganz verschiedenen
perspektiven als muster als als dort
erkennt und wenn man jetzt alle
möglichen abschattungen diesem
neuronales netz ein gelernt hat könnte
man nach einem bestimmten auffassung
durchaus sagen dass es den begriff etwas
realistisch verstand und perspektivisch
nicht aber das war eine interessante
frage dann der interessante frage
interessantes thema wäre was
informationen ein riesending da könnten
sie dann zb den begriff der infos fähre
nach eine cherry flori die eingehen also
information ist da gibt es dann eine
hermeneutische modell als informationen
codiert dekodiert solche
kommunikationsmodelle dann könnte man
sich fragen hat informationen was mit
relevanz zu tun also hängt es auch vom
betrachter des interesses rat als solche
fragen da ist luciano flori dieser
oxforder internet forscher eine der
führenden vertreter den könnten sie
darauf
dazu verfügen darauf können sich
beziehen auf ihn und ein weiteres thema
ist folgendes wie funktionieren
künstliche neuronale netze ein vergleich
zu unserem gehirn können diese netze
unser denken simulieren was man den
bruder gewandt
61 und was könnte man sich andere fragen
hatte die frage nach der abbildung von
biologischen strukturen digital
da müssten sie eben so ein bisschen auf
die funktionsweise eines neuronalen
netzes eines künstlichen eingehen wir
haben das ausführlich immer und
versuchen die nähen und unterschiede
darzustellen und sich eben auch zur
frage inwiefern es dann auch auf die
erste frage sich beziehen lässt und
liefert er überhaupt an so eine form von
intelligenz unterhalten kann
herr professor nieder romme zeigte es
sind alles algorithmen und dadurch das
kann es irgendwann gewinnt mit dem coach
passt ist kann es kein intelligenz haben
das würde ich so schnell nicht sagen das
hängt natürlich ganz wesentlich darauf
adressen künftig bestehen aber
neuronalen netzes sind so komplex dass
sie mir scheint
neue form von intelligenz zumindest
simulieren und wenig zucker auch
virtualisiert und glaube dass wir
zwischen land sondern die virtualität
deutlich unterscheiden müssen das wird
auch das thema der heutigen sitzung ein
weiteres haus aber als thema wäre wie
dann ist das internet philosophisch
relevant worin besteht seine strukturen
bestimmt städtischen publik
da ist natürlich über 3 fuß auf den wir
heute noch mal kurz zu sprechen kommt
will eine präferenz hat das buch an die
internet geschrieben erst auflage 2001
gab es noch gar nicht so viele homepages
sie erinnert sich noch an die stadt ist
sind diese beiden waren noch sehr klein
der gaszuleitung 820 millionen homepage
35 vielleicht 100 aber nicht mehr und
mittlerweile gibt es fast eine milliarde
homepages oder vielleicht auch ein
untermenü stoppel bin mir jetzt gar
nicht sicher bin ich mir gar nicht
sicher aber als robert dreyfuss ist dass
du der welt vertreten
über das umfeld schreiben und dann ein
anderes thema das wir heute eingehen
worin besteht der unterschied zwischen
realität virtualität in simulationen mit
die grundsätzliche ontologische frage zu
sagen also digitalität digitalisierung
ist nur ein fall von wirtschaftlicher
wird realität und die digitalisierung
oder digitalität wie auch immer - das
paradeboot der virtualität wie auch das
internet eben das paradigma für die
medialität werden also wir haben das
gesagt das ist transzendentalen zu
verstehen das ist die bedingung der
möglichkeit von medien steht überhaupt
und mit jener täter heißt vermittlung
und das internet ist die basis dann
schienen vermitteln könnte man bekommt
dann noch mal darauf zu sprechen
hatten sie dieses diesem podcast gehört
dem massen ins internet gestellt haben
wir haben einen podcast also
autorisierten und gemacht haben wir das
internet wenn sie mal auf youtube gehen
oder auf film cast können sich das nach
der vierten stunde haben wir darüber
gesprochen das unternehmen als wir sind
der meinung dass das internet so eine
art grundbedürfnis geworden ist oder
wie zum beispiel strom wasser
elektrizität
wer heutzutage mehr daten hotelzimmer
wer möchte nicht nur fließend wasser der
möchte nicht nur strom der möchte nicht
nur wärme gewünscht auch internet haben
und für 50 jahren war vielleicht auch
wenn man noch
wir haben er hatte oder vor 100 jahren
viel wenn man elektrizität hatte unter
telefon oder sommers messe aber als ich
glaube dass das mittlerweile zur
grundausstattung gehört und dass eine
wohnung ohne wahl fall dass der etwas
grundsätzliches fehlt und das zeigt eben
auch dass das internet ist ein
grundbedürfnis geworden ist eine grund
die mission die unser ganzes leben
begleitet und unsere lebenswelt
durchdringt dann habe ich sie noch
darauf hingewiesen dass es jetzt eine
bibliographie gibt zu finden die unter
dieser adresse für lokales funknetz
schrägstrich bibliographie bindestrich
digitalität finden sie alle bisher
behandelten texte zu ihrer biografischen
ordnung und auch die können sie sich
die textstelle ich auch noch alle
digital ins internet zugänglich dass sie
die nummer herunterladen können sie
finden alle verweise auf diese texte
bereits in den folien die ich gehe ja
immer recht zugänglich war und die sie
auch heute wieder hier unten drin unter
diesem video finden zum herunter
diese bibliographie wird auch ständig
aktualisieren da kommen immer weitere
titel und geografie und der letzten
sitzung hatten wir das thema internet
behandelt
ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz darauf
eingehen also hier an den tag über
dreyfus der war jemand der universität
2011 gewesen hatte meister kostet geben
war sehr sehr spannend
ich habe mir auch ein paar keksen
gemacht wie kann ich ihnen vielleicht
auch noch zugänglich machen wir haben
über alles mögliche geredet auch eine
virtuelle welten
man hat ihm dieses buch geschrieben
diese grenzen der intelligenz das ist ja
schon recht alt ist unser 72 und dann
hat er eben dieses recht aktuelle buch
haben die internet geschrieben second
edition des 2008er ist der auflage des
2001 gewesen und jetzt habt ihr hier
eben in diesem diesem zitat des mystery
internet ist justin
bruno menschen ist in italien als es
nicht irgendetwas sondern es ist etwas
ganz grundsätzliches deshalb bei einem
zitat das is different ist also etwas
ganz spezifisches sagt so viel dass es
die wirklich die typische die alle
grundsätzlich sste form des mediums ist
jetzt möchte ich hier noch auf ein zitat
eingehen was wir noch nicht behandelt
hat der letzten sitzung und zwar geht es
jetzt um den körper
wir müssen uns fragen wie wir im
internet überhaupt noch körperliche
wesen sind wie für unser körper da noch
eine rolle spielt und das ist für herrn
weber 3 fuß ein kritikpunkt leser
vorkommt und im ausdruck findet
inklusion grange fr commissario
brunettis djs world trade center demenz
und ausbauplanung also das internet ist
auch etwas was uns nach einer entsetzt
dass es uns erlaubt uns bei körperlichen
grenzen internationale transportieren
und jetzt sagte weiter bei auch buddy
inception vision 110 terminator ii auch
physiker war der bus frontex
flexibilität
gehört hatte smit mcphee des redakteurs
europäischen kontext und wir uns links
und peter wenn du many ways mehr export
wird dieser point mit empfehlenswert es
zu instrument dessen sortiment der in
klosters wechselburg mobility also diese
leere netz enthusiasten die glauben dass
mit unserer verkörpern im moment eben
auch wenns endlichkeit unsere
verletzlichkeit mit gemeint ist und dass
diese verletzt können dann endlichkeit
dass die durch das internet eben nicht
mehr so stahl und vordergrund tritt
ja das ist also soll diese auffassung
und hier steht natürlich der gedanke der
befreiung dahinter die befreiungen von
unserem körper von unendlichen struktur
und jetzt ist typisch 103 fuß der schaft
ist so ganz modernen dinge wie internet
wieder rück zu bringen mit zu ganz alten
dingen wie zb platte also sagt liegende
behind the flash player große breite
semeta die horste tun sollen volks
aktive clement wird in schutz wir jungen
teams euskaltel-euskadi bekannt also
das ist so ein grundsätzlicher alter
gedanke der griechen die griechen wissen
alle wissen zumindest sein kann das
wahlrecht körper skeptisch ich sage sich
körper fallenden aber recht körper
kritischen körper feindlich waren sie
bestimmt nicht weil wenn sie diese wesen
kennen diese schönen antiken vasen und
olympischen spielen den sport die wagen
auch durchaus körperlich präsent und der
körper keine schönheit hat was in der
rolle gespielt aber philosophisch gibt's
mit dennis die dann auch nietzsche des
apollinischen gegensatz zum
zionistischen des apollinischen das ist
wenn diese mit der philosophie von
sokrates verbunden dass man diese über
ort und des verstandes dance über die
sinnlichkeit über den körper es gibt
einen griechischen intellektualismus so
kann man das nennen
der sagt das absolut wirklich
existierende ist nur durch unsere
unserem verstand und zur vernunft
erfasst das sind die ideen und ideen
existieren auf eine andere weise alltag
existieren körper nur ist existieren
überzeitlich über räumlich und antwort
und die sind das war existente und zum
beispiel der bau der konkrete baum 1000
der existiert nur weile anteil hat an
dieser idee weil er dies indem
exemplifiziert und weil er seine ex
exemplifiziert hat ist er vergänglich
gebaut werden zugrunde irgendwann mal
120 slams mit daher genauso wie wir auch
und jedenfalls in dieser wirklichen welt
und dann gibt es eben doch die ideenwelt
jetzt nur durch unsere winter legt nur
kognitiv zugänglich nicht wieso er sich
durch unsere augen zu
obwohl die griechen sagten wir sehen in
dem wir schauen sie aber mit unserer
geistigen auge hatte für die griechen
die ganz ganz große bedeutung
das ist nicht für alle wo kult und alles
ging manchem kultur für die ihr das eine
große rolle spielt dafür sprechen auch
viele gründe ball wird den sinn
erfassend durch das jeweilige sprache
durch das ohr trägt und wir sind nur
sehr schlecht visuell erfassen können
arbeiteten tag und wir haben so ein
höheres auge ein seelisches auge indem
wir diese ideen diese vorbilder
die seen und insofern hätten sich würde
jetzt drei fonds sagen die griechen sehr
gefreut wenn sie schon internet gehabt
hätten
weil das internet gesaugt oder in einer
gewissen hinsicht das verkörpert oder im
bad nicht verkörpert was ist die
griechen unter diese gilt es die
körperlichkeit der zeitlosigkeit die
raum der lustigkeit existieren im
internet existieren raum und zeitlose
mitteilen
und das wäre zu eine form unserem körper
hinter uns zu lassen
finden wir ganz ganz spannende idee und
das ist so das zeichnet uns aus dass das
schaffen des antichristen mit dem aller
modernsten zusammenzubringen
der spot potent in die skating medien
der freudigen eine clevere become
independent film water for service hat
es also müssen unabhängig werden
unabhängig von unserem körper von den
räumlichen zeitlichen grenzen die uns
die wirklichkeit umgesetzt
ja die von jetzt an flosse für eine
korrektur ein notwendiges specific uses
of praise question is expected to what
if the times sind
nordafrika ist erster developers second
life bekannt dann festival haben
alternative kann sport ins internet
gehen als access zu und herrschenden
second line to extend camp teil eines
insiders becks gut mit bekannter ort in
flammen
es ist nämlich so dass das was er hier
als möglichkeit was wäre wenn als ihr
reales das hier bezeichnet das natürlich
schon längst realität geworden lassen
werden und zwar eigentlich schon zu
einer zeit wo die erste auflage dieses
erschien 2001 ein bisschen später kam
world of warcraft ausnahme ich glaube
2003 wir also unsere 2002 und diesen
fans in der heimat
dreimal also zwei jahre später als etwas
geschrieben hat war das realität wunsch
davor solche spiele bis dafür auch weil
man da solche identitäten an hatte also
wörter vor klopp würde ich sagen ist so
eines der ersten spiele vielleicht noch
diablo 2 diablo 2 k 98 2000 aber behörde
vor kraft ist es erstens würde ich jetzt
mal sorgen etliche massenphänomen
wirklich auch ein second life hat und
was er hier konjunktiv bezeichnet das
wurde schon kurz darauf geriet er jetzt
sagt das wort ist in sequence of film
and the possibility wird wenn mit enter
cyberspace geblieben wie halt auf einem
porsche kulturtipps ist ihr den bonner
verein paris 11 in der begegnung mit
marco rubio freedom und labour mit
fortwährend links remake des zehn teilen
das ist seriös samt crew schon passiert
aber würde zum exzess vingst
distinguished relevant from the sense of
the series of success fehlen wird es
nächstes ziel verhören dauer nicht
gewachsen und groupon robert gibbs auf
aussehens auf der reality of things naja
ich bin nicht ganz sicher ich weiß nicht
wie sie das sehen
lassen wir wirklich im cyberspace in
unsere emotionale wie emotionalität
zurück unsere innovationen zurück unsere
verlässlichkeit zurück ich würde es so
nicht sagen
ich würde sagen im cyberspace entsteht
eine neue form von emotionalität von
intervention von situiert halt von
vernetzter eine frage ist der mann ganz
groß was heißt schon war der anschlag
galt in cyberspace
genau
also ich glaube dass er das wirklich nur
von außen an bestimmten sehr
konservativen sicht betrachtet ich
glaube dass man das ganze alles diese
ganzen verletzlichkeiten alles auch auf
der ebene der digitalität darstellen
kann natürlich jetzt nicht körperliche
fähigkeiten im internet werden die
körperlich verletzt endlich auf eine
andere weise bestimmt schon dann darf
nur an cyber- mobbing der immer gesagt
also psyche sind wir auf jeden fall
vielleicht noch viel verletzlicher im
internet
das precise in der richtig behauptungen
wir sagen tatsächlich cyberspace blieben
also irgendwie münchen haben so dass
eben dieser körper reichsten das wüsste
was ist das tatsächlich funktioniere und
das ist so viel jedenfalls einem schönen
den fragen offen
um diese umfrage ist dass eigentlich
diese übersetzung des tieres lebens des
geistes im cyberspace das mit dem ball
musste das erste nicht kam
unsere jetzt in titel darstellen
auf diesem treffen möglich ist dass wir
persönlich glaube oder ob es möglich ist
dass das kind überhaupt davon geben also
ist es mit allen gedankenspielen hier
als oder punkt wir müssen natürlich
vorsieht seien diese philosophie des
geistes überzustrapazieren
also körper an körper geist journalismus
geben die sonst kognitiven eigenschaften
wie die auf unsere leiblichen
eigenschaft angewiesen sind und das ist
sicherlich ein ideal des internets
grille ganzen digitalisierung unsere
kognitiven eigenschaften loszulösen von
körperlich das ist auch die anti pickel
das antike kritisch anti mit ja dass das
metall völlig zu simulieren und körper
sie kennen das alle von hand von den
dekan in seinen meditationen
jeder von ihnen kennt diese erste
meditation ganz wichtiges wird dessen
klassiker und bekannt steht der eigenen
tradition der antike einkaufstag mein
ich also mein eigentliches interesse des
weges kam ich separieren von meinem
körper
es gibt denkende den als in der existenz
des rheintaler für sich ist existent und
es kann man die tränen vom körperlichen
es ist eine unterscheidung von
lesekompetenz der substanz um die rede
sechs tänzer dass die denken ist die
ausgeglichenste denken die substanz und
die terrassen denken und extension
sollen außerdem substanz prozent ist die
außenwelt ist unser körper die karte in
einer gewissen tradition zu artikeln
dass wir uns im internet phänomene
unserer mentalität abtreten
und da sagt natürlich größer
wissenschaften alle die philosophie
heute so ein geist es nicht das geht so
einfach nicht
also körper und geist in wechselwirkung
miteinander stehen und da ist auch klar
dass das ding ist bei menschen das
geistige praktisch fungierte durch das
gehirn des natur ihren das heißt nicht
dass alle mentalen phänomen erklärt
werden könnte reduziert werden können
auch wenn auf materielle arbeite steht
zumindest sehr gerne steuern und
wechselt netz die frage und das glück
auch die mentalität können wir im sinne
von die krise des kapitalismus werde die
kohle die devisen kannst separieren
vitalität dafür dass in seiner digital
struktur unsere können wir das zu
verlieren wie gewissermaßen wie die
software wie die software in einer hart
wäre also dass das betriebssystem klonen
und woanders konservieren und dann
irgendwie er gewann den körper zu führen
das ist natürlich ein additives modell
dieser vorstellung zu finden dass ihr
körperliches und geistiges einfach so
auseinander dividieren können soll
zusammensetzen können und da bin ich
auch sehr skeptisch bundesagent even
verstehen können wenn man der
digitalität auch als teil der disco beat
ansehen also nicht auf separaten sondern
im vierten teil bereits gute kannst ja
ich glaube dass geister gestaltung ist
einstige
dass das eine gewisse ich würde ich weiß
und ich muß ich bin ich gesagt ich würde
sagen es hat eine gewisse analogie zum
der digitalität und zwar deswegen weil
ihm das traumlos ist ein zeitloses und
vollzieht sich nicht treu mich als wenn
ich an etwas denke das andersdenken dann
kann ich das nicht bereut ich direkt
beschreiben und ich kann es eigentlich
auch nicht direkt zeitlich beschreiben
also wenn ich jetzt ein gedanke
beschreibe ein gedankengang vermisst die
beschreibung des gedanken ganz von
andere art als wenn ich beschreibe wie
die zeit dieser stift auf diesem pult
liegt zusage liegt hier hat diese
richtung liegt zu dieser zeit dort ich
kann natürlich sagen
um zu dieser zeit punkt 12 43 am 14
juni hatte ich diesen gedanken okay aber
das spielt für die geltung des gedankens
kann ich dir gedanken hatte spielt für
den gedanken kommen keine rolle wenn ich
ein gedanke beschreiben mit einem gang
an stelle ich diesen gedanken kann mich
freue mich da wo ich damals die gedanken
gedacht hat spielt eigentlich auf den
gedanken kann und auch zeitlich ist ein
gedankengang anders verfasst als zum
beispiel ein prozess in der welt in den
physischen er ist das wenn man das
gedanken sind in einer anderen struktur
gedanken sind eher würde ich sagen
über textuelle verbindung assoziative
gedanken und das meint damit bin ich ja
hier gibt es eine gewisse energie statt
mehr
viele fragen seien ich glaube dass der
hypertext und diese ratlosigkeit
zeitlosigkeit diese anthologie des
internets in der ersten täters die mir
zumindest analogie aufweist in dem
geistig es ist einfach nicht im griff
hat ist letztlich dadurch nicht
vollständig
das heißt es lässt sich nicht
beschreiben das ist heißt aber nicht
dass ich mich richtig ist es nicht
anders nennen
sag ich mal eine ökologische frage ob es
ist in kann ohne dass die andere ist die
exekutive der kritische fragen ich
möchte es noch offen lassen
ich würde zunächst erstmal zunächst mal
sagen dass
[Musik]
ja das würde ich jetzt unterscheiden
denn das design von digitalisierung
seien konsolidierung wäre es die
qualität also digitalisierung werden die
technische seite welche server brauche
ich ermöglichen speicherkapazität
welches medium wie die technikseite
technische seite und es wird
die kulturelle philosophisch zu
digitalisieren
da interessiert uns dann die konkrete
technische realisierung des kurses und
ich glaube dass wir hier der alpin card
und zwar wissen
anzeigen und loben laut zeitung dass das
hier eine ganze stadt lesen deswegen
haben wir die leute auf die idee wir
könnten unsere mentale inhalte kopieren
das internet wir könnten da eins zu eins
bisher stellt das wäre ein spannendes
thema von hausarbeiten die fans oft wer
oder mit digital struktur geben unsere
geheizt uns im mentalen phänomene auf
eine analogie abbilden oder vielleicht
gar nicht nur ökologisch zurück unter
logisch genau das sehen ist das gedanken
und digitale objekte wie sie mitten im
internet vorkommen dass die das selbst
dass sie von derselben art weil sie
virtuell sind
man müsse sich jetzt vor allem sind so
genannten virtuellen willkommen wer ist
der virtualität zu sprechen aber das
wäre eine möglichkeit
also hier weil ich muss sagen das ist
jetzt hier eben dieses dieser punkt der
körperlichkeit und jetzt bringt er hier
noch mal diese übersicht die haben wir
auch so ein bisschen behandelt können
sie dazu über was sagen was es damit auf
sich hat und wie es möglich ist muss
hier ganz präsentieren in der schweiz
zwischen library culture und darüber
dass zwischen einen hyperlink als
schafft und diese hyperlink alter die
würde ich mit denn mit dem begriff der
digitalität in verbindung
das ist das was unter der digitalität
bestehen also links ist die analogie
kultur die alte bücherei kultur die
klassifikationen hier ist stabil
allerdings ist stada fix ist eine
hierarchische organisation und das ist
nach spezifischen interessen kopiert
wenn sie meine bücher alten bücherei
katalog amerikas es ist ganz schwierig
unserem zettel
kasten vertikale strukturen auszubilden
den zettelkasten ist ganz stark dass
werden dass wir dass das wetter
und dann gibt es aber mal so vertikale
verweist vergleiche dass das sind auf
der mehr als 1000 diese unterscheidung
hat vertikal das ist als vertikal wie
horizontal und das hier diese ebene
horizontale die ist würde ich sagen wir
wegen des inhalts des hypertext die
verlegung versehen
und wenn sie in zelten kassen haben ist
es ganz schwierig solche vertikale
können verhältnisse der horizontal
verhältnis herzustellen nicht kennst die
ein kurzer exkurs kennen sie sich mit
zettelkästen etwas auskennen sie mit
laszlo man in diesen funktionen schon
mal gehört habe wo man glaubt man einem
soziologen 70er 80er und er hat einen
ganz berühmten zettelkasten entwickelt
und diesen zettelkasten das war eben
damals die state of the art damals 70
80er diesen zettelkasten hat er
wahnsinnig viele verlinkungen
hergestellt als er hat verwiesen
von dieser zettel spielen ja auch
unser cent kosten
iran so komplex dass er aus diesem
zettelkasten durch eine gewisse
systematik wie er den zettel dann
angeordnet hat und man wieder neu
beschriftet hat seine werke traust
gemacht hat an dieser zettelkasten vasen
art generator eine art quelle für seine
ganzen werk seine bildung soziologischen
in dieser zertifikate erworben worden
und gehört das glaube ich eine
universität ich weiß gar nicht welche
rinnen und nur gebiet gehört das
eigentlich weise aus bochum muss oder
die andere uni und erzählt im kasten ist
jetzt soll ausgestellt und jetzt gibt es
das projekt diesen zettelkasten zu
digitalisieren
also das kann man die tormitte überlegen
und über texten macht überlebensanzug
will damit nur sagen dass das ganze
konnten auch schon suchen analog
herzustellen aber es war schon
unglaublich spielt unglaublich schwierig
mit damals ein zehntel verloren ging
oder nicht mehr lesbar war usw
er war war die sache letztendlich sehr
sehr betroffen
funktionalität haben wir bei der hypo
linken hat alencar kaufe ich mir und es
ist vor allem flexibel wir können
ständig neue zu bauen bevor nehmen und
die einspeisung das internet
funktioniert auch viel leichter als wir
mit einer neuen begriff anlegen 19
also darauf vor dem immerhin beweisen
ist eine intersexuelle evolution das ist
ständig organisches im organischen
wachsen
sie muss man aufpassen über deine
begleitung im teil zu betrachten
um es nicht ähnliche organisation swiss
made sind die geschwindigkeit und die
arktis zu küssen sich unterscheiden die
in seiner priorität und da ist schon
gelesen
verweis auf andere bücher kann
mutig spannungskurve andersen dem gegen
rest ausgeholt
das heißt wenn ich endlich auch mal so
teilte er funktionieren genau sind ein
gutes ende noch ein respektloses wenige
zwei plätze stehen könnte man zu sagen
dass man sagen es ist ihre nur
quantitativ unterschiede nicht
qualitativen als einfach schneller und
flexibler habe ich denen der unterschied
ist der dass es physikalisch gebunden
ist an bestimmte zettel bestimmte
systematisch lässt solche systematik und
von bibliotheken sind ziemlich stark
sie können sehr vertraut waren mit der
systematik des regensburger verbundes
katalogs das ziert die systematik
unserer bibliothek theologie philosophie
ist ziemlich stark gegen blicken was
selbst den betrieb also beispiel haben
den unterschied zwischen übrigen auch
das heißt es kann der verein wohl
unterscheiden werden
[Musik]
genau jetzt habe ich hier dann in frage
wenn wir die reform tanzausbildung
digitalität als weitere ebene einführen
haben wir da noch vieles zur realität
unser denken verlieren wir die angenehme
stimmung das ist eine berechtigte frage
also die frage nach unserer identität
also wie fern kamen so eines von gut
tanzen denken sonst an überhaupt noch
ihre einheit bewahren und viele linzer
einheit und die individualität dieses
geistigen ermöglicht durch die
verkörperung durch die körper und raum
zeit durch unseren körper
unser körper individuelle unseres unsere
metall trinken und wenn wir jetzt auch
den körper ganz verzichten
ja was passiert damit
flüchtig der sind stellen sie es noch
vor zuvor wir werden sie informationen
ins internet einspeisen
die verläuft die hat er keine klaren
konturen keine grenzen als wir setzen
unsere identität ausleihen können wir
digitalität können wir dann in den tee
oder auch so die aktivität so wie wir
sie jetzt kennen unserem leben berichten
was mit dem geistigen die einheit an die
betonierung individualität wenn es nicht
mehr der körper ist nicht mehr braucht
macht nach dem tod es ist wäre eben
solche märz ohne frage werden wir nicht
angewiesen sind auch ganzen körper dann
gehen damit ganze konsequenzen her dass
das ideal der kirchen das ganze ewigkeit
erreichen wenn wir uns im körper hinter
uns lassen
da steht natürlich der gedanke die
erzähle dahinter die seele die und
können wir loslösen war ist aber man
muss sich wirklich fragen liefern kann
es ist ein geist einheit individualität
bewahren und nichts zu blättern
gewissermaßen sich verlieren wenn der
körper nicht mehr
ja man kann sagen kinder befreit worden
sind
hier braucht ein weiterleben grafik
ganzseitig sofortige unterschrieben okay
aber der lette die politik ist es wie
man die bücher beiden ich ein buch und
ich lese selbst das buch ok und das
vermitteln
da habe ich gleich noch mal mit ihm
sprechen könnte mich dann basierend auf
den dax das jahr hat und den ich auch
mal das buch oder das sind
und im internet geben werde ganz anders
vor
man erkannte den artikel zu lesen und
die da verstehe ich das nicht ich schaue
hier haben hat und weiter und das ist
nicht ganz politisch immer da ist er an
den opfern trainer denkt ihr habt ihr
hier sind das boot sondern dich
informieren sich über das thema das wäre
zum beispiel auch ein spannendes thema
pressefreiheit gegen wie überhaupt
rezipiert wird wie überhaupt
intellektuellen gearbeitet wird oder
gedacht wird oft eben das internet
zugreifen mit der analogen ist ob es
eine qualitativ oder gehe ich aus wie
ein quanten die im unterschied ein
gewaltiger
genau wir müssen schauen ob es neue
qualitäten gibt es einen neuen phänomens
an der meldung er ist ganz dort den
ganzen sie hier
aber auch die möglichkeiten und der
qualitative unterschied beispielsweise
es gibt diese schlag form zu finden gibt
es sicherlich aber sie ist eben weit
nicht so komplex diesen wald nicht zu
aktuell und überlebens immer die
schnellste ebene hinkommen thema
medialität sie kommen mit einem klick
kommen sie zu diesen zu diesem anderen
werden mit einem klick
und da kann man jetzt sagen es ist nur
quantitativ weil wir in der analogen
bibliothek noch mal sozusagen für die
schritte machen müssen oder ich muss
jedenfalls muss man zum anderen stehen
werden
aber ich glaube dass entscheidet
wirklich dass so ein klick ist und dass
es wieder diese unmittelbarkeit des
internets die ist ein klick struktur ich
habe mal einem anderen kontext gesang
da ging es um digitale wäre pro weiteren
klick dem der studierende benötigt um
auf inhalte zu kommen verlieren wir die
hälfte genutzt
das ist jetzt nun erfahrung aber ich
glaube es ist wirklich so wenig drei
klicks braucht um an informationen zu
kommen
sprich wenn ich mich noch einbauen muss
wenn ich dann noch mal an weiter reden
muss und dann irgendwie doch mal ein
häkchen setzen muss verliere ich dreimal
hilft würde ich jetzt darum das heißt
die 1 klick struktur ist es allerdings
dass ein klick und das man eben die
unbedingt magazin möchte reichenberger
philosophie zu dem thema risiko geraten
damit dass in der schweiz der auf den
projekten losgeschnitten der neueste
version des uni ist offen
dies verkürzt sind denn das wäre so
vernetzt wie das repariert mit einem
monster 2001 wesentlich jetzt bild des
inzwischen verfassung hier und jetzt
werde die lesung von philosophen werden
immer gut er war erst der erste super
wenn der hinweis als der wittgenstein
war natürlich auch ein total analoger
denke eigentlich aber wir sind geständig
wenn's mal im tractatus und den
philosophen fassen sie hatten schon mal
gelesen eingelesen das system muss
mitglieder und ist ich weiß nicht wissen
wie für die ebene bestimmt über
kopfhörer dazu gehören 46 es geht also
wird der zug nach punktuell tiefe und
wie sie richtig sagen gibt es dann
verweise und da da und das ist glaube
ich nicht das könnte natürlich prima
über das hypertext machen dass man sagt
ihr springe ich wieder dahinter ein
das ist gerät auch so ein bisschen
seinem denkweise weil wittgenstein
bestimmten phase jedenfalls gar nichts
der tractatus turnieren den lösung stand
durchsuchungen ihre spiele geschrieben
hat recht solistisch waren also wo
eigentlich fast schon so eine art von
digital itc entwickelt hat finde ich
spannender punkt 20 ist ganz nach hinten
deswegen die heiße feuchte verstehen was
bedeutet das internet aus die neue
struktur ist dass es in dieser 1880 und
was diese fördert das land und die stadt
das system in der politik haben
zusammen und so weiter sind später der
gegend hat das projekt ist also weiter
die handlung zwischen schnellen zu
ermöglichen
das ist eine entscheidung bei der
eigenen persönlichen herangehensweise ob
ich das ganze bild einen schnell zum
zehnten systemen die materie haben
möchte was jedoch die gleichen
dimensionen sind wirklich so weiter und
so fort
unglaublich da für eine bibliothek der
seite sind es jährlich etwa über
strukturen vernetzung von komplexen
systeme aber keine zukunft
sie haben recht also von der genese hier
von der genese von der stimmung her ist
der hypertext hinterhalt das internet es
gab ganz alter bedürftig systeme und
auch mit touchscreen wenn sie mir auf
wikipedia.de kontext eingeben gibt es
ein bild wo man so ein monitor sieht wo
jemand darin klingt oder so das war noch
kein internet der hypertext bis dort
deutlich eltern von seiner idee her von
der struktur aber man hört jetzt sagen
der über text hat seine erfüllung oder
sein weg erst langt im internet also
erst durch die entwicklung des von html
und so weiter so forderte anderen
sprachen oder für protokoll erst durch
das internet und seine erfindung hat
sich der hypertext dahin entwickelt
wohin der in seinem wesen nach liegt
weil das internet wissen dass wenig über
aus dem hypertext lesens wesens konform
ist
alle andere form von über texten sind
nur so ein bisschen lösung gibt die die
lassen sich realisieren dabei sind noch
verbunden mit vielen hindernissen und
der hypertext kommt zu seinem geld um
erst da wo im internet eingesetzt so
könnte man auch das ist abgestellt
eigentliche einsatz das eigentliche
einsatzgebiet des hypertext ist alles
davor die ganze gelogen strukturen sind
nur so ja so zu dass ihr mit er und
damit vier reibungsverlusten verbunden
also der text kommt das derzeit seine
geltung aber sein recht gibt schon davor
erweisen sich dort hatten sie sich noch
gemeldet nicht dass er persönlich
vorstellt war auch die stille aushalten
sehr guter bruder punktgenau dass man
mal belegt zu hausarbeiten nicht so sehr
[Musik]
vertikal
ich nenne ich komme hier von unseren
oben nach unten oder wie auch immer
jedenfalls so und das arbeiten mit
horizont
dann kann man darüber reden ob sie das
auch in diesem seminar machen dürfen
also was man sich überlegen könnten wäre
das ziel das sie in hyper hyper
textarbeit streiten dass sie mehr auf
diese version ist hin und mehr mit
verlinkt werden
das heißt es wird auch der fokus für
dritte gebe vom dies seien von dieser
rhetorischen arbeit von einem thema zum
nächsten hin zu schreiben und es ist ja
auch meine ausbildung gedanken zu lenken
in einer vertikale profile fokus auf
inhalt glaube ich ja manchmal wenn man
will erklärungen zu einem thema hier ja
als ich denke dieses vertikalen denken
ist hier definitiv im präsident des
logischen ableitung dann müssen muss
genau dann muss das gedanken reihenfolge
geben und im landtag wäre dies in folge
nicht mehr so notiert werden diese
strengen den und tiefes logische rein
fertigung ihre lippen
dann wäre es egal von welchem punkt aus
dem beginnen kann hier gegeben ich kann
in berlin spielt keine rolle
während es logisch unter dem motiv sind
es fertig gespielt
prinzip das heißt es innerhalb der
regierung
das können wir von jedem beliebigen
punkt den wir können von jedem
beliebigen punkt ins internet einsteigen
ihr könnt die ganze sache aufziehen von
jedem vermieter davon fordern wir können
es fährt sozusagen satteln wir wollen
aufzeigen sondern in form und das geht
bei vertical modell nicht dann müssen
der eine punkt ansetzt wir müssen ein
und ausgang und auf diese horizontale
ist egal wo wir einst das ist ihr die
solistische internet gedanken das ist
dieses dezentrale den zentralisierung
während die vertikal ist schon ganz
zentral ist
jetzt könnte man sich überlegen da
müssen wir darüber reden ob sie nicht
auch mal eine performative also adäquate
hausarbeit über dieses thema schreiben
wo sie selbst die hausarbeit horizontal
verfassen und auch über das schreiben
performativ wir sehen also eine hyper
link über lync verfasste arbeit mehr
abgeben
das können sie machen indem sie einfach
daneben wir verweisen machen können wir
müssen aber darüber sprechen wenn sie
das wollen kann man darüber sprechen
werden extrem ich bin ja für experimente
einfach um dieses wesens und text im
medium des hypertext zu respektieren
so jetzt haben wir gesagt die erste
hälfte in der sitzung wieder verwendet
um nochmals anzufassen
warum jetzt geht es um die ist ganz
etwas ein thema qualität
das ist ich glaube dass der zentrale
begriff und mich hat er auch einen
kollegen der carotis special thanks to a
m herr dr kalium des hehren wären da hat
mich darauf hingewiesen dass eigentlich
noch viel grundlegender als der begriff
der digitalität der begriff der
virtualität ist leider eben nicht nur
sich im medium der politik interessieren
verwirrten virtualität ist doch ein
größeres phänomen verdient die vitalität
nur ein teil eine teilmenge könnte man
sagen ich habe bald folgen
wie verhalten sich realität virtualität
simulation zueinander das scheint ganz
wichtig dass man nicht glaube dass man
dazwischen unterscheiden können ob ich
eben kann sich virtualität zeigen also
wohl behalten
nicht nur im internet inwiefern kann man
objektiv ein bisschen komisch und
theologischen zwischen diesen drei modi
als realität wird heute
simulation unterschreiben anbietern
verändert sich das verhältnis dieser
drei modi unter den bewegungen der
digitalität das in so ein paar fragen
und jetzt mit getreide vier beispiele
die manieren geldschein und bitcoins es
geht es um virtualität niefern sind
geldscheine virtuell
also ich bin ich tatsächlich hingegen
ganz gegen gut deutsch
aber nun habe ich zwei gdf das geld ist
ja eine nur ein symbol für einen wert
der wirklichkeit nicht dagegen sein
sagen wenn sie wenn sie das wesen des
geldscheins oder des bankwesens sich
genau anschauen dann haben sie den
ersten hinweis auf hinweise auf die
wirkungsweise der virtualität dass ein
virtueller wird in dem sinn dass die
aussagen nicht richtig realisiert
physikalisch verkörpert oder
substantiiert ist also ist was anderes
ob ich jetzt hier in einem goldbarren
gebe oder ob ich ihnen hier den check
machen das war ganz schön scheckig dem
werk des goldbarrens nur mit meiner
handschrift was anderes und ritter
möglichkeit wer nur wenig nehmen wenn
sie mir so klein wollen waren geben 1000
geben es ist genauso virtuellen check in
check für die noch viel virtuellen weil
der wirklich immer von meiner
unterschrift von der authentizität
meiner der unterschrift von meiner
authentifizierung und ich glaube dass
dazu nicht stark der geht dann mit dem
virtualität enthalten ist wir müssen uns
ist gleich woher kommt es dass wir das
so ein wertloser papierstreifen wie es
ein scheck auf jeden fall mit dem scheck
hat
kein wert gar keine die gelben karten
werden
wir haben geld scheint so 1000 soll ich
würde mal sagen kostet erfolg ich weiß
es nicht der herstellung der hersteller
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger gefühl
mehr für weniger vielleicht ein problem
aber darf nicht zu viel kosten seines
unterscheidungen zwischen boden und dem
eigentlichen leben schreiben schneide
dass das ist erstmal auch nicht ziel ist
ganz klar im übrigen die welt habe hatte
den spenden und ich kann nichts
bestätigen konnte steht das ergebnis
über darf nicht das ist was technisches
system information das in kohle selbst
kann sich außerdem dadurch jederzeit
weist man sich eine willkommene ausgehen
dass sie aktiv 1000 positiv
dieses unseren kunden übertragen und
dann bei der esa der symbolischen
charakter der das freie und kritische
mehr dabei sein
ja also bei bitkom ist natürlich etwas
anders aussehen es auch gar nicht eine
betreuungs wie kompliziert das ist eine
wissenschaft für sich
sie haben jedenfalls recht dass es
gewisse abhängigkeiten gibt die nicht
willkürlich sind beim bitkom gibt es
gewisse regeln und zwar ganz viele
regeln die diesen wert konzentrieren
bleiben wir mal der einfachheit halber
nur meinem geld schafft bitkom gibt dann
zu komplizieren nur bei den geldscheinen
sich noch drin
ich denke dass mehr dass wir immer
zugesprochen
ob das salz ist oder es fällt der
verkauf hat sicherlich den oder in konz
trier und mainz sicher nicht der wert
das ist natürlich etwas was
zum schreiben games des salzes für
andere wurde als guter punkt wurde uns
geht es um den wert es geht mir bedeutet
erwähnten verfahren uns jetzt woher
kommt bekommt interesse an dem ich dann
bedeutung
wir machen sie habe völlig recht
ungünstig wenn sie diese dieses buch
eine kurze geschichte der menschheit
[Musik]
kennt das und er kommt aber an alter
stelle auch darauf zu sprechen und sagen
es gab ganz früh da hat man mit muscheln
gerne 20 uhr schwimmen und die haben ja
eigentlich gar keinen besonderen wert
auf die frage woher kommt es dass ein
gegenstand einen wert bekommen in die
stadt fährt
was genau auf diesen berg und
vereinbarten man einfach auch den nutzen
für 1 euro gespart werden
[Musik]
davon habe ich das mal genauer also
einmal den nutzen oder den vorteil der
mann hat also pragmatisch könnten sagt
dem nutzt die scheiben also keine daten
das heißt nicht dass alle spanischen
[Musik]
welt wenn man mir irgendeinen stein gibt
irgendein staat ganz ganz passt und mir
irgendwie etwas zu essen dann kann man
natürlich sagen es hängt von der
situation ab
wenn ich den stein ganz dringend brauche
ganz glücklich weil er mich nur mit
einem steigung etwas machen kann was ich
jetzt machen möchte und was wir viel
bringt dann hätte natürlich in der
situation dieser steigen die größte
größere wertung das heißt kurz zusammen
situation als 200 sind nicht individuell
aber wenn wir mal davon abstrahieren sie
kennen diese filme wo jemand ein
königreich gibt es irgendwas ganz
unbedeutendes wollen dieses unbedeutende
teilt ihm oder ihr diese situation zu
überleben helfen könnte dann wird es
ganz anders als es geht
die situation den kontext aber dann bin
ich auch könnte man sagen den nutzen und
natürlich auch um das interesse und weil
das natürlich jetzt fast zur kollege
bedeutung wollen wir ja erklären kann
man mit interesse habe ich denke
situation und interesse das ist der
kontext innerhalb dessen verglichen wird
zwischen verschiedenen objekte die
müssen natürlich immer bezogen werden
auch nicht ob wir uns natürlich auch das
gute wetter im inneren des volkes für
mich nützlich weil ich noch mal
angesehen
und wenn wir natürlich auch als wir
müssen auf jeden fall der lesung von
dieser reihe werden sich diesmal der fan
aber ich denke wir werden jetzt die
gesellschaft kommen dann ist sicherlich
der nutzen wichtig und jetzt kommt eben
dort um den sieg gebracht haben das war
die vereinbarung
sie vereinbaren wenn nutzen das
interesse der kontext ist ziemlich
konkret also natürlich kommt etwas an
wert
aber doch einer bestimmten situation für
mich wenden wenn eben dieses trends ist
aber ungewiss ist ein wert oder
bedeutung zuzusprechen
die dieser gegenstand dauerhaft oder auf
einem gewissen zeitlichen ausdehnung
jetzt muss noch was anderes also
natürlich kann man sah eine spezielle
situation wo ich jetzt diesen standort
zu beleben aus irgendwelchen gründen
klar hat der stadt diesen wert aber wenn
die situation verwaltung nämlich nicht
mehr diese situation finden wird der
stein wissen wer verliert das heißt
gefragt woher kommt es dass geben
stimmte dauerhaft in der geringen
relativen der streckung natürlich nicht
ewig bei gold kann man sich fragen aber
stellen sich mal vor stellt euch mal vor
wir hätten jetzt ein verfahren
entwickelt das war im mittelalter
ständig so der versuch gold künstlich
herzustellen sie mal vor es wäre jemand
keller auf eine geniale idee und seine
mission salzsäure und der mission noch
dass das und tut ein bisschen billiges
metall rein oder würde zu gold dann
werde der wert des goldes weg das haben
wir natürlich nicht verstanden
damals und einiges machen müssen wenn
das gelungen wäre
diese müssten dann hätten die sich
selbst erzählen
nicht wertlos gemacht ist eine gewisse
zeit ihres lebens hätten zu viel geld
gemacht aber auf lange sicht liegen
werden wer zur inflation bekommen
dh es muss aus dem gewisser mangel dass
mangel oder seltenheit und halter
probiert was an wert legt indes zählen
ist dann ist etwas besonderes
natürlich ist nicht alles erzählen ist
gleich schon wertvoll aber das scheint
mir auch ein wichtiger punkt sein dass
esra ist ein knappes ja zb spanien
hatten das gold wurde in london gold
gemacht nachdem es dem seegebiet im jahr
transportiert und im pazifischen
atlantischen raum gestellt in den fünf
kugeln wie wir das machen sollen weiß
die persönlichkeit das ding
genau deswegen sollten wir werden nicht
mehr
[Musik]
es ist guter punkt genau es mit den
gewürzen die gewürze waren ja auch
unglaublich teuer
safran ist immer noch sehr teuer und
wenn sie mal genau schauen wo mit der
zusammen das waren extremst regulierte
handelswege über bestimmte fahrer
führten die dann wiederum steuern
erhoben usw
als die portugiesen um 1500 anderen
handelsweg fangen um afrika herum
konnten sie venedig das wasser abgraben
weil bis dahin hat der venedig einen
ganzen gewürzhandel kontrolliert im
ganzen 15 jahren davor war venedig wir
haben uns macht in kürze es ging nach
asien kann man durch von indien und als
die portugiesen über afrika gefahren
sind hatten sie den seeweg zu den
gewürzen und haben damit venedig das
wasser beträgt also bald einfach dann
viel mehr von dieser menge oder viel
weniger besteuerungs situation in umlauf
gebracht hat also es gibt und knappheit
ist auch ein wichtiger punkt und was ist
aber nicht
gehen sie jetzt schon unsere geldschein
da geht es nicht um knappheit ist ein
geldschein sondern geht es um hier sehe
ich das ja kein vertrauen und
konventionen es muss es muss eine
bürgschaft da sein muss auch bei
spekulation zum beispiel diese tröten
die sache ist ja als vier oder fünf
vertrauen konventionen also wenn wir
kein vertrauen haben in institutionen
würden und institutionen mir keine
situation haben
dafür wird keine verfassung keine
haftung
dann würde alles sein wird verliert wir
bekommen werden stabile abstrakte wird
nur wenn wir es mit institutionen zu tun
haben die natürlich ende auf werbung
sagt auch vertrauen das wir versprechen
[Musik]
system wir sagen den märkten nicht wir
haben den gegenstand gerade in sachen
verfügbarkeit von geld eben selber
verwaltung heißt wenn jemand ein werder
missverständnis herausgestellt dass
im controller der sprecher zu kommen wie
die entscheidung ausfällt muss weiter
das wissen die geldmenge erhalten
genau das ist sie
das problem ist wie sie vielleicht auch
wissen aus dieser inflationszeit wenn
das so unscheinbar 0 bekommt man kann es
nicht mit dem drucken alleine regeln
wenn man mehr den schalldruck dann
verliert das wird genauso problematisch
wenn man zu wenig druck und die leute um
ihr geld haben von der banken bekommt
man nicht und scheidet aus
es ist ein ganz außer tailliertes system
[Musik]
kapiert es muss ein stabiler konnte ist
seine rahmen die mehrheit wären das
ganze läuft
bitcoins ist wie gesagt ein riesending
na da kann noch so viele themen rein
finde ich auch ein spannendes thema
zuhause bei also virtualität virtuelle
existenz mit 100 wert am ball kommt der
bitkom ein entspanntes team youtube
abonnenten ist das virtuelle feel like
some und dlcs sechs likes gut hier zu
schauen also das ist auch ein bisschen
virtuell natürlich steckt dahinter eine
person kunstwerke
da haben wir stecken nicht gut
am besten man schaut
[Musik]
genauso ich könnte jetzt zum beispiel
auch mir hier könnt ihr live kaufen
vielleicht nicht gepasst hätte auf jeden
fall ins heimathaus halle wirkt wenn ich
jetzt hier
wir kaufen will 1000 likes oder noch mal
1000 zuschauer dann hätte das eine
bedeutung war in meinem video wurde
bestimmt häufiger auf youtube
angepriesen werden und ich würde
vielleicht irgendwann sogar einnahmen
generieren durch ist woher aus gibt es
auch nur bestimmte nutzer zahl für die
man damit geld zu machen noch lange
wesentlich
[Musik]
wir werden unternehmen wie youtube hause
nicht viele leute das animiert haben
zum laufen wie viele leute sich das
video ansehen und lang sie sich hier
ansehen
da gibt es erst recht möglich
genau da gibt es ganz viel
analysemethoden sie können ja auch wenn
sie im youtube-kanal haben analysieren
wie lange die videos angeschaut wurden
unsere urzeitlichen publikum endlich
weit und so weiter zu fahren gibt es
viele kunstwerke damit noch kurz
eingehen nehmen lässt sich einen
beliebigen gegenstand haben diesen
stimmt ich legte jetzt hier an diesem
tisch ist es ein kunstwerk
trotzdem wäre das wäre vielleicht zu
begeben michael jackson irgendwie von
michael jackson diese diese diesen hut
den er drauf hat
der könnte noch so billig sein und wenn
es auch michael jackson getragen hat
dann bekommt ihr ein bär plötzlich das
interessant das gibt es ein weiterer
faktor personalisierung und abstrahlt
oder strahlt er diese die berühmtheit
von michael jackson die die firma auf
sein gutes wertlos der ist hier stinkt
der route der ist verschwitzt ich weiß
nicht was alles haben die leute wollen
ja wahrscheinlich auch weil es so selten
ist weil nicht so viele hüte hatte wenn
michael jackson täglich unter der hütte
getragen hätte und sie etwas vorgebracht
hätte hätte der hut auch nicht wert wir
kommen gleich auf die besondere note
digital life der hauptrolle ist aber sie
noch genau wann ich kann es gar kurzen
rede war
alle anderen arbeiten arbeiten bräuchten
ein zertifikat das ist jetzt wieder hier
verlangt haben dass ihnen zertifiziert
dass es sich dabei um den umfang einer
jackson- haben ja das könnte ja und es
ist der richtige kommt sieht die fahrer
nur dann gewährt wenn sie in sieht das
ganze paket bekommen für eine
institution und heben
hätte er für mich den gleichen und
darstellen können
ja aber ich würde sagen es muss die
systemstabilität gestern die täter in
der regel nur erreicht wenn es um das
original
also kann man fragen ist es wirklich
also wir brauchen stabilität und
vertrauen das ist so die bedingungen
aber zurück zum kunstwerk
wenn ich den stift jetzt hier in einem
museum legen angenommen
ich gehe jetzt zur pinakothek der
moderne und diese stift und lege ihn in
einer vitrine und einen ganz großen
lichtdurchfluteten raum ins zentrum
dieses stück war in einem betrieb mit
einer glaskuppel trainerin
was ist dann und um die idee wird
kuratoren der der neuen pinakothek
lassen nicht das macht die sagen ich was
wollen sie es nicht mehr kommen sie
bitte links im stiftungs dahin mit
handschuhen und so weiter zu holen und
so das ist das also
und welche design oder oder erst
bestimmt werden
sie kennen alle tasten einem pissoir
den franzosen schon genau die chancen
nur ein pissoir umgedreht aufgehängt ich
weiß ja irgendwie umgedrehten also so
oder anders wird schneiden den
zweiteiler stiftung legen diese
triumphatoren sagt olga bitte mit der
linken und dann beschwört sie stehen 100
unterläuft und folgt dann ist es mir
letztendlich auch wieder eine
eingliederung ein bestehendes system und
sei es egal ob ost oder das museum oder
sei es teile des betriebssystems zu
kunst in dem zusammenhang und ist
eingespielt wird dass uns eine garantie
gibt oder einzusteigen
dessen kann natürlich nach und vor allem
wo es alles kunst zeit genug wenn es um
richtlinien konkret präsentiert gemacht
denken sie an die brüder boxen
wesentlich wertes hergestellt hat die
übung genau in die woche der kommt aus
kitz gesagt da gibt es pizza museum
vernimmt er hat einfach so brüder boxen
so werde oder cola touristen und ready
made in dieser art und antwort und
alltagsgegenstände hat er einfach alles
kunst ausgegeben und sich sagt ins
gericht ich sowas muss dazu noch nicht
sagt wenn ich jetzt hier mit dem stift
in die neue pinakothek
die würden sie einen kopfhörer und nicht
aussteigen würden die würden den wert
sein wollen
das unternehmen habe seine hier mit dem
stift märkte ausgerichtet
dh hier fehlt es an vertrauen der fans
an kontext an krankheit und auch ein
phänomen das ist unglücklich und also
renomee wenn jetzt die wochen denke ich
weiß ich weiß
berühmter künstler hier einfach kein
rennen würde zeigen wir hier stellt
ausmachen lassen mich nicht als heißt es
geht um kontext und das wiederum
interessantes geht in der vereinbarung
zwar auch um einen wirtschaft und
forderungen die bürgschaft das museum
ist dran wenn sie einem jemandem
reinlassen wie mich und irgendwas
ausstellen lassen dann sind die dran
dann geht es den antrag wahrscheinlich
aber wenn das heißt sie haben die haft
müssen genau wissen was sie als kunst
ein leistungen nicht und dann wird es
irgendwann ganz spitz sagen was ist
jetzt daran kunst sehen es geht um das
thema von einem baum einen juristischen
kontext es kam im einzel gar nicht mehr
sieht
es gab jüngst eine untersuchung warum
eingriffen ein künstler 100 mal so viel
wert ist wie das bild von einem anderen
künstler der mit ihm studiert hat und
haben aus gefunden er hatte das kann man
wissenschaft und nachgeprüft im
management seien zudem in seiner
zeitschrift hat und das veröffentlicht
man konnte nach
dass der künstler dessen teurer war
obwohl es qualitativ von derselben
hardware selbst schule sehr ausbildung
dass der einfach frühzeitig schon die
kontakte hergestellt haben zu den
richtigen galerien
er hat sich sehr schnell ins spiel
gebracht als name das heißt der politik
betrieben und das trägt dazu bei auch
bekanntheit kann bekanntheit und auf den
marktwert bekanntheit naturbad sollte
dass jemand sich dreist dass jemand
bekannt ist dass direkt zum wert auch
mal virtuell genau zu ihr seid desto
punkt jetzt das heißt wir fragen uns an
zum beispiel geld scheint die dieser
wert bis an die virtuellen der wird
nicht real und substituieren ich habe
den goldbarren nicht da und auch in
goldbarren könnte irgendwie virtuelles
ich nenne es auch mehr bedeute dass
diese ganze realität bekommt dieser
diese
dieser geldschein oder diese dieser
check
ganz einfach man hier durch das ganze
system durch das netzwerk indem er
besteht in den bezügen die in dem er
steht und diese bezüge sind nicht
willkürlich sind die bezüge in denen
dieser scheck steht die sind
reglementiert die sind juristisch
verfasste sind abgesichert sind
verfielen institutionen gedeckt und in
diesem kontext diesen ganz fest
gefüllten hochkomplexen kontext
innerhalb dieses kontext des erst
bekommen dieses dieses papier seine sein
wird rituell oder fehlstellungen geil
weil ich würde den begriff der
vereinbarung von als überschrift gegen
alles was da tut es mir ja vereinbaren
muss ihm nur zum vereinbaren ich muss
die investitionen waren war dies alles
scheinbar hast oberbegriff gilt die
vereinbarung war gar nicht mal das
vergessen
das würde dazu erfassen institution nach
ist ja auch in den vereinigten staaten
ist kann ich das vergessen es geht um
den kommunikation unterzentrum einen
diskurs der besonders kohärentes nach
wie man das ganz abstrakt und ein
besonders cool denton des kurs um eine
einhaltung von regeln letztlich eine
regelhaftigkeit um eine ganz ganz
komplexe struktur eine kohärenz von
struktur die kommunikativ auch noch mit
gewissen verbindlichkeiten versprechen
uns von der abhängigkeit
diesen wert erzeugen lässt wenn nur zwei
leute sagen ja gut
hier wird für eine neue während meiner
stimme jetzt 1000 euro wert und sie alle
stimmen wir zu und sagen ja und dann
gehe ich jetzt zum meckern sagt hier
1000 brötchen hier bittet die teams
ihren kopf sollte aber hier wird durch
garantiert von dem platz ganz hinten
[Musik]
lagen
virtualität erst mit der abbildung von
etwas konkretes steht
ich kann das verfahren werde
es ist schon einmalig bei der städte
sondern etwas etwas zugewiesen wird was
selber mal abgebildet werden kann
das heißt wenn ich wenn ich zum beispiel
sagen
schade für mich begrüßt mich erfinden
und dessen was nicht schlafen des
ägyptischen staates können verschieben
werden muss die rolle zu erstellen oder
nationen haben scharf fleisch oder so
jetzt herrschen
das heißt wer dagegen wehren dass sonst
ragt ist was wiederum die überaus einem
system der ergebnisanstieg
das typische gemeldet werden kann sie
sagen es wirklich zur echten geldschein
ist keine abbildung mit deutschland
bildet keinen wert ab das steht für
etwas drehen durch die der
trainerausbildung
das ist was abstrakt ist was anderes ist
es wenn man es mit virtuellen
gegenständen zu tun haben wie zum
beispiel zum computerspielen
da würde ich aber auch sagen das sind
keine simulation würde nicht sagen dass
simulation sind virtuelle identitäten
sie simulieren nichts an sie das
imitieren vielleicht und simulieren am
anfang aber sie gehen über die bloße
simulation hinaus weil sie die eigene
realität bekommt weil es in eine wert
bekommen das ist bei simulation nicht
der fall
simulationen sind ganz klar abhängig von
den ursprünglichen real wäre man sie
ständig im dienst sind ganz klar
untergeordnet sie können aber kein
eigenleben und das ist bei der
virtualität und jetzt möchte ich noch
kurz hier
wir haben über den tod von michael
jackson gesprochen
jetzt möchte ich hier auf diesen routen
geben bis kennt
sie glaube braucht die region skane
werte 1086 usd ein paar kennen sie
runescape zum endspiel das ist so ein
verhalten ist ein online rollenspiel das
soll erst in java programmiert worden
zum 2009 98 schon hat es immer weiter
verbessert und jetzt ist es ziemlich
attraktiv diese schicke party roth der
kostet 1700 dollar recht als müssen sie
zahlen können auch in gold bauzeit klein
das ist jetzt dritter virtuelle realität
hier sehen sie plötzlich wer ist gleich
ein bisschen was simuliert der der gut
aber der sieht doch gar nicht aus ist
eine chronik
ich weiß das ist gegenstand werde es
irgendeine zahl ausstattungsgegenständen
und als hut ziehen sie dem nicht auf
sich selbst das ist ein schmuck
vielleicht ausstattung ihres charakters
1700 immer weiter es gibt noch eine
andere kennt sie das
das ist second life amsterdam dieses
amsterdam viertel second life kostet
50.000 wohnungen sollen noch besser hier
dieser klub in volkers crystal palace
club neverdie für 330.000 dollar ist
also wird in einer online lieblingsklub
daumen
diesen gelegen und es hat jemand von
330.000 dollar gekauft hatte dann
aufgeteilt in verschiedene segmente und
die dann untereinander verkaufen am ende
alles für 600.000 verkauft hat also
großen gewinn gemacht werden
also das ist der teuerste gegenstand
dieser kopien ist das ist somit also mal
geht es gibt wirklich in auf die
millionen zu was virtuelle gegenstände
seca gegenstand ist in virtuelle welten
teil bereit ist diese details kann
gegenstand club sk des instituts genauso
mit amsterdam muss auch kein leben
stammt ist eigentlich ne ne welt gibt
von diablo 3 gibt es noch so eine
armbrust gekostet zu 1000 2000 euro
dollar also dass er sehne sich hier das
virtuelle virtuelle realität das kostet
geld fehlen
die leute machen mit warum woher kommt
der wert diese dinge bekommt er wird
warum zeit sondern 300.000 oder dessen
christa pers
hier sollen denn das kauft der hat mir
das angesehen wird an schließlich selber
[Musik]
richtig nutzen ja dass wichtiges bericht
auf dieser seite nicht genau was
verkauft
das heißt nämlich eine konkrete
online-welt von mehreren nutzern besucht
werden kann habe ich eigentlich um
kritisiert oder entschied diese sicht
existiert und sich darin kaum statt was
wir überhaupt kaufen kann es jeder dass
ich gut spiele im vorbericht von mir
jeder kennzahlen soll das weitergehen
vielleicht zum beispiel ist unsere auch
noch die wm dritte andré santos
lebensmodell amsterdam ist eine weitere
verwendung von amsterdam präsentiert
werden zum beispiel zu werden wie zum
beispiel
das urheberrecht als ist entsprechend
schon alles geht um ein system von
vereinbarung jetzt endlich auch
rechtlich es geht um eine rechtliche
ordnung
die vertrauen voraussetzt die eine
stabile gesellschaft voraussetzt die
auch so was wie eine jurisdiktion wie
die gewaltenteilung einem set
voraussetzt wenn du mich dass da nicht
bekomme dann kann es ergeben klagen ich
hab' das bezahlen
das heißt es werte setzen ein ganz
stabiles system der gesellschaft voraus
online vertrauensbasis mit rechten und
so fort
aber da sehen sie mal es gibt noch einen
teuren ring statistik dann aus dem
planeten den man kaufen kann man kurz
glaubt 1 millionen das machen wir ja
jedenfalls so viel dazu dass es läuft
aktuell und jetzt haben wir es hier mit
dem oxford hamburg port authority zu tun
und da habe ich einen aufsatz stirbt aus
die jetzt im lesen möchte jetzt geht es
um diese fragen wie verhalten sich
virtualität simulation realität die
amerikaner kennen noch hält die karriere
zerstört camping aktualität oder wenn
mir sagen aktualität mal wieder damit
etwas anders um die aktualität sagen
die relevanz die neuheit die zeitgemäße
antwort ja genau
wirklich keinen realität genau also
wirklichkeit im gegensatz zu möglichkeit
ja okay das wird also jetzt sagt er hier
in dem age of the world realität
relationship to reality ar charity als
eine realität und möglichkeit gut ist
lambert heißt wächst die akademie von
managers wohl die pousadas denning und
bekommt von max josef der passion of
that konzert sound express edition found
in the case for public art italiens mod
inkarnation virtuelle tiere und beim
increasing digital relations zur seite
als er sagt die virtualität die gibt es
eine schonung unabhängig von der
digitalisierung aber er ist und einer
wachsen sind digitalisierung der pc
schon bekommt die virtualität in einem
nur eine besondere virtuelle welt
scheint das ist nicht digital aber genau
so können wir das sagen haben jetzt
virtuelle welten weil wir eben damit
gewisse dinge korrigieren können und
haben als den titel
im digital erschaffen können das heißt
sie haben viel mehr möglichkeiten
kreativ zu werden und virtuelle
realitäten zu schaffen man sagt das ist
also der relevant aber es geht hervor
es ist nicht nur möglich virtualität im
rahmen der digitalisierung wird
vollendet besonders relevant da wo wir
es mit digitalisierung zu tragen
du kannst gerätes pattinson
konstitutionelle virtual hasselblad oder
einem konzern im netz technische
direktion wird ideas and applications
auf 100 modern den ställen virtuality
amiri lebens zu der party party also
wieder hier gesagt es gibt schon lange
davor warnt orientieren
virtualität ist nicht erst da
aufgetreten wo wir es mit
digitalisierung zu tun das ist glaube
ich ein wichtiger händler ist und jetzt
geht es also eine frage was denn jetzt
ein virtueller gegenstand der bringt es
zum beispiel eines apfels deshalb kann
man belebt auch jackson virtual
environments anderen wehren weil die
kombinierte meetings ausschuss frühere
wärterinnen wurde diese gut da diese
blaue party good for example the series
und aber beim mähen scroll of austria
hatte hathaway jessica locations place
the chemical company
beim witch project object
wie es aber kein automatismus report
into action weeks ist instead of just
imagine represented virtual im
krankenhaus testen los zur sportstadt
ezb am mac beliebt jack tisch wischen
protection and response to computer
inkonstant nottingham workshop sechs
countrymusiker kix wenn dort kein
support a day made in 49 geschäftsführer
des trägers und physik und cold case mit
sun virtualbox ist der virtual cash game
wenn sie also digitale spiele drittel
aus monte play jazz wollte motoren
gebaut in wales es gab keine virtual man
qualifying speak and exchange portals
markantes präsentierte case für virgin
money bekannt in server virtual
workstation in sounds and personal user
ja es sind aber auch sehr sehr gerne
hier kommen die mit die metaphysik und
bonn mit
analysierende brutalität rein es geht um
die frage von nicht existent
entgegenstellt oder objekt oder ob sie
eben dort existieren ja bis jetzt aus
bönen hat sind aus existiert wirklich
sehen dieser text hat zwei teile
er sagt jetzt also also diese apfel
damit dem kann man nicht hat keine
physische keinen raum zeitlichen stelle
und auf zeit er hat keine physikalischen
chemischen eigenschaften kann ich wieder
besser agieren und er ist nur eine
glaubens filmprojekt zu aber wenn sie
eben nicht reale physikalisch nachdenkt
was daraufhin dessen sie da jetzt blicke
das beispiel dieses schachspiels wenn
sie kennen sie ließ es kennt ihr das
glück ist für mich gut
und ja es ist kein wirkliches spiel und
währungen zu leichten beleidigung an ein
packendes und es keine wirklichen
beleidigung die verursachen doch
kränkung weil die leute sie haben eine
kausale kraft ist soll sich dann bloß
rituell
die ich sagen würde das nur nebenbei das
zb
keller brachte nicht reichen bauten seit
es das erste group vor einigen jahren
sind haben
bewegungen worden erstellen genau diese
position dieses achter
das heißt die frage ist natürlich sehr
viel in vergleichbarer abschluss der gut
ein spezieller gerade beliebtheit die
entscheidungsfrage die ersten experten
hineingespielt es aber aus gemünd es
innerhalb dieses spiel ist wollen wir
die möglichkeiten selbst gegenstand
unter den toten waren dateien zu
bekommen und zu erhalten
ich habe das auf jeden fall diese daten
in einem rucksack den server aufgang hat
nun das gas dann habe ich meine einzige
gegenstand überhaupt funktionieren
existieren mitgliedschaft was genau das
ist ein riesenproblem sein erstes und
computer wichtig wobei dazu noch einige
anträge kommen nämlich wenn sie wirklich
kaufen muss ich das ganze system ist
waggons und mit der zukunft ist ein
riesen kontext wenn er nicht da ist
können sie noch so viel passieren und es
hat kein geld
sie müssen sie kaufen sie dieses
und jeder der gestern für so viele der
net dass die sittlichkeit geselligkeit
ist daher das wenige was auch die kultur
aus die zweite natur
sie sehen jetzt plötzlich hauptklage
zwei traktoren mit ihren institutionen
mit ihren gerichten mit ihrer polizei
usw
die scheint auch irgendwie mit ins
digitale reihen zu spielen ebenfalls
vorausgesetzt werden zu müssen damit wir
virtuelle werte überhaupt etablieren
können wenn wir da nicht die zweite
natur mit kultur mit dem rechts mit der
teilung der gewalten und gerichte haben
dann ist schwer aus dass stabile werte
zu generieren bezüglich des spiels das
sind ich versuche zu gelangen
mit einem spiel sind virtuellen chancen
unsere werke auf die man sich einlassen
deswegen mann
auf der tastatur sowie martin aber nach
eigentlich recht personen die bis in die
haarspitzen pausen beim schwimmen durch
die regelwerke ob das jetzt physisch an
fast meisterschaft bisher genau hier
könnte noch weitergehen
es bessert ratings zu der west unsere
mitarbeiter der spielt so gut schafft
der spielt sogar schach blind alle der
braucht keine figuren gesagt werden
er sagt einfach b4 man sagt der anderen
c3 und das merken die guten
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler
melden sich das einfach im gehirn und
das spiel trotzdem stark dass überhaupt
würde wie eine physikalische bewegung
stadt getan hat es sind rein wolfs
letztendlich bräute man es auch gar
nicht artikulieren sondern müsste
einfach nur die idee haben muss nicht
kommunizieren muss die kommunikation
statt für die brauchen nicht über das
internet stattfinden die kann auch
einfach blind ohne man muss sich
natürlich vorstellen aber es werden
bloße muss dann letztendlich die die
spielerinnen und spieler aus
[Musik]
wir mussten ja muss kann ich gar nicht
mal photographs gericht die zeit wenn
man lange genug blindschacht spielt dann
verinnerlicht man das so das kann jeder
von uns überhaupt nicht das könnte jeder
von uns wenn er oder sie nur lange genug
um schach spielt dann kommt es von
version glaube ich schon weil ich da
[Musik]
kippt man sie gibt es architekt ist was
anderes dessen in die beethovenhalle
dafür konnte trotzdem komponieren
gedacht so meinen sie was genau
genau das könnte auch in der musik sein
dass man die sind diese technologien
erkennt und sie vielleicht gehört es
nicht
base raum könnten zu entfalten
genau bestehen als absoluter gehört dass
das kann man ja erlernt also wenn ich
jetzt hier dieses dsa höhere oder sagen
das ist jetzt zwar schlecht es um das
vorsingen das kann ich nicht während das
muss ich haben
auch dieses video mehr
kompositionspreis ich auch wenn es mit
den patienten
das holen
drei struktur findet auch das gehör
[Musik]
das technische vorgang
das sind es immer als frauen dazu lässt
diesen weiterer interessanter punkt wie
man jede woche in der die tiere ingo das
kann durchaus sein ziel ich gehöre es
gibt eben viele viele künstler ganz
bekannte künstler kandinsky 12 der hängt
ja auch im lenbachhaus der hat natürlich
komposition oder klavierstücke hat der
farblich gesehen ganz toll reisen.de
jetzt einmal kurz zurück zu dem apfel
wie sie zu hause möchte einfach mal
fragen ganz am ende ist der apfel in
diesem spiel oder diese blauen gut in
skate dieser party mit 2086 dollar wie
es stets mit ihnen
wie sieht's aus dass das wird schnell
klar warum ist die virtuell
bei der keine physische hat aber muss
alles was real sein reales physisch
seien zum beispiel situationen verträge
ist noch jahr und das institut weist
aber sie ist eingebettet auf jeden fall
die musik werden wisst ihr ja also woher
wollt müsst ihr jetzt auf eine zu fragen
woher bekommen dieser party gut diese
virtuelle gegenstand dieser party hut im
juni wohl bekommt er seine wirklichkeit
oder auch seinen wert gebacken
woher bekommt er sein werden
ja sozusagen eine gewaltige personen
braucht es eigentlich
ja das ist ein guter punkt also kann es
so sagen wenn ich jetzt auch blaue
virtuelle gegenstände stehen genügend
einig dass sich das interesse haben und
dafür bereit wären zu zahlen also in der
es ähnlich könnte man das zumindest nur
mein individueller wenn es halt für mich
von werte ist punkt aus unbekanntem wert
es ist die einfachste arbeit ist die
einfachste antwort sagen wenn es mich
geben interessiert wenn es mir das wert
ist eine bezahlung
damit wäre das dann letztendlich ein
wert den wir nicht weiter analysieren
es wäre höchst willkürlicher
individuelle werte mir nicht objektiv
erklären können weshalb gefälscht er hat
auf leute die mit zehn krone oder zehn
zahlen
das wäre die einfachste anvertraut
aber wenn wir uns um stabile werte wenn
wir zum beispiel in diesem spiel 1000
leute haben
ich denke dass wir dann wieder
diese klarheit geben ihrem gewissen
begrenzt zeit und es muss auch dafür
gesorgt werden dass sie nicht am
laufenden band hier künstliche party
hüten eingespeist werden von server das
neuwieder inflation von einer party gibt
und das ist eben wieder dieses system
des vertrauens unserer geben das gilt
natürlich auch nicht bezahlen das ist
auch digital vielleicht sogar viel
einfacher möglich das leben
diese diese werte konstant bleiben dass
dieser wohl nicht inflationär verwendet
wird und dass er eben auch denjenigen
der es kaufte gegeben wird und dass
seine funktionalität im rahmen der
digitalität eben auch erhalten weil das
wir nun einmal den ich hatte gegen ist
es diese dieses zitat kennt sie ja der
wirklich erfüllen kann
interagieren mit objekten integriert
werden na ja so ein paar kilo zu blauer
kann in minsk ehre auch interagieren mit
anderen gegenständen die virtuelle dass
es genau dieselbe struktur würde er kann
sogar noch viel interessanter
interagieren
eines nachts in den tödlichen bild weil
der viel wie unabhängigkeit von raum
zeit also drehte interaktivität genau
als dauerhafter der apfel den hässig des
weg der apfel wird nach ein paar tagen
wenn sie mit der sonne weg wird was
passiert mit dem nicht sagt ich habe mir
den film seine stabilität die persistenz
da haben das wieder mit diesem körper
losigkeit die wir dann bei den antiken
kannten das ist dann so
die lbb stadt nicht vergänglich ist
zumindest solange wiederspiel ist gut er
kann wieder hergestellt werden eine
sicherheitskopie aber wenn wir zum
beispiel eine verletzungen stattfindet
mit einem in ihren
urheberrechtsverletzungen wird dieses
spiel eingestimmt
denn wenn das wenn es gerichtlich
verboten wird dieses spiel weiterhin zu
betreiben
wenn dieses vertrauen wenn dieser
kontext des vertrauens gezogen wird
gerecht - und dann ist es vorbei mit der
programmdaten kann genau sagen würde ich
vorschlagen
daneben ist groß
ich würde sagen alles trocken ich würde
sagen es gehe ich würde da kein chef der
grenze ziehen sind ich würde sagen es
geht um die 1000 kraft und
verbindlichkeit dessen etwas außen
je mehr verbindlichkeit in ihr kommt
jetzt ein baum vertrauen in der kausale
kraft gelder sich geltung verschaffen
einen gegenstand seines virtuellen hat
umso realer und unsere glücklich also da
würde ich gar keinen strick
unterschieden zu haben das scheint mir
ein bisschen kürzer aber darüber können
sie sehr guten hausarbeit schreiben als
woher kommt die realität auf den
virtuellen oder die wirklichkeit
theologische sein
wir müssen das ganze natürlich auch von
simulationen grinsen ist mannheim
wechseln sie ziemlich auch simulationen
unterscheidet sich dahinter bringen
gehen von virtualität dass der
simulation nur eine ganz schwache
wirklichkeit orientieren zu können
insofern die simulation immer abhängig
ist von dem real und physikalisch und
wer auch immer gegenstand
es geht um ein abhängigkeitsverhältnis
und hierbei den blauen party gut hat
sich eine emanzipation durchgesetzt
dieser blaue fertig und der simuliert
keine blauen in der wirklichkeit
er hat eine eigene logik der die eigene
form vielleicht gar keinen
verwaltungsabteilung charakter mir ist
eine eigen nennt
die halt getan wurde wird er wisse aber
er kann sehr wohl wirkung entfalten mehr
als jeder andere pilot ich wüsste keine
personen schrecklichen party wohl für
den 1007 punkten müsste ich nicht kenne
ich keinen wirklichen müssen wie man
jetzt sagen ich weiß nicht noch nicht
also spannende frage da sieht man dass
virtuelle gegenstände eine viel größere
causa alle kraft besitzen könnten durch
stimmen als physikalische objekte tun
es geht um den kontext erhalten lässt
sind dieser gegenstand ist seine
bedeutung gewinnen und das ist natürlich
auch mit kunst tracks so auch hier ein
kunstwerk würde ich sagen hat erst sein
wird in diesem kontext in dem die werte
zugeschrieben werden das ist jetzt ein
bisschen konstruktivistisch gebe ich zu
es gibt es traditionelle auffassung von
kunstwerken dass der gegenstand aufgrund
seiner schönheit und seine tonart
spezialität einem wert besitzt denken
die antike statuen die einfach aufgrund
ihrer handwerkskunst diesen wert besaß
aber auch da würde ich sagen ist ein
bisschen abhängig eine andere zeit würde
man sah ist der kitsch es gibt ja auch
okay wenn wir die werte haben sich das
ist die frage
dass die frage aus deutschen museum
das ist ja der alten pinakothek und der
marktwert des deutschen museums starke
bildrauschen werden 1000 mehr überall
und chinakohl faktor 1000 faktor 1000
die teuerung und sie keine kosten
ich glaube dass das das sind diese
entsprechend anders sind werte die dort
ausgestellt werden und zwar unikate als
unikate und auch geschichtliche
zeugnisse alles ist die zeugnisse die
jetzt nicht nur künstlich sind einfach
es sind dokumente die raritäten sind
weil es unikate sind weil es die ersten
gegenstände sender weil hier etwas
ausstrahlt
aber jedenfalls denke ich auch dass und
museum wie ein kontext ist er halt in
diese ganzen rechten vertrauen wichtig
diese schätzen des museums letztendlich
nur ein und jeder kontext der und sagt
hier gelten diese diese regeln die
überhaupt wert generieren und realität
ermöglichen
vielen dank für die mitarbeit wir haben
jetzt heute ein spannendes thema
angeschnitten
die situation der nächsten sitzung geben
wir darauf noch einmal genauer
eingelesen diese zitate durch die können
sich nochmal durchschauen
auf diese folien oder nächsten sitzung
wenden wir uns dann in spanien dazu
nämlich der ästhetik der digitalität der
versionen da allerdings reife zugs in
künstliche virtuelle welten ist und in
computer spielt das ist ein natürliches
angst meine persönlichen lieblingstitel
dann bis nichts